lo primero antes de empezar quiero
decirles que no no no qué podemos acción
de estar en su ciudad amo este lugar de
verdad es un lugar que para mí
representa muchísimo y es bellísimo
muchas muchas gracias por su
hospitalidad bueno gracias bueno pues
vamos a platicar hoy de lo que de lo que
denominó vive tu propia serie así que
como buen todo por un programa de
televisión empezamos con la temporada 1
este y de qué se trata esto
damas y caballeros la realidad de
nuestras vidas es que todos tenemos
héroes todos y cada uno de nosotros
y porque tenemos héroes porque es de
naturaleza humana inspirarse entonces
bueno que es inspiración pues
inspiración inspiración si vamos a
analizarla es el proceso porque el cual
mentalmente se está estimulando para
hacer o pensar algo si eso es lo que es
inspirarse
pero pero si nos vamos más allá de la de
la limitada definición o de la semántica
definición podemos partir de inspiración
en su raíz del latín que es espíritus
espíritus es que significa aliento es
parte intrínseca obviamente de
inspiración todos qué bonito no qué
padre qué inspiración a final de cuentas
significa el brindar aliento
ya que viene esto si nosotros como seres
humanos naturalmente y evidentemente
tenemos que respirar para vivir pues
evidentemente tenemos que estar
inspirados para vivir
ay les va un cuentito si se acuerdan en
algún momento en la biblia dicen por ahí
que estaba estaba dios y se puso a hacer
con su plastilina y una cosa que llamó
ser humano y le quedó bastante padre la
verdad es que estaba estaba muy
inspirado en ese momento y ya y ya
cuando acabó ya quedó su obra terminada
dice sabes que pues para que esto viva
para que esto ya tenga vida pues le vert
y le brinda el aliento se les brinda
aliento en el estos que es lo que hizo
dios en este momento puesto que hizo
dios es básicamente inspirar al ser
humano padre no es muy muy muy bonito
entonces es por eso que esta naturaleza
es a ese componente es tan tan parte de
nosotros mismos
y bueno pues voy a dejar estos viejos
testamentos para otro momento pero este
vamos vamos a la aplicación en la vida
real no yo les aseguro que más de uno de
ustedes ha estado en ese maravilloso
momento en esta maravillosa situación es
el doscientos años aniversario de sus
abuelos
ya sabes y tienes esta fiesta que dónde
va a venir toda toda toda toda la
familia de todos lados del mundo nos
están contando pero bueno los tíos que
jamás has conocido los primos que jamás
conociste etcétera esté todo el mundo
está todo mundo está listo para celebrar
los a los abuelos y tú tuviste la
brillante ocurrencia de alzar la mano
decir lo hacemos en mi casa no qué
diablos no entonces este visual pues
ahora le va lo hacemos allí en su casa
no y entonces empieza toda esta vorágine
de detalles que tienes que atender que
todo esté listo porque mente quieres
quedar bien no entonces pues te matas
preparando que hasta que las servilletas
estén dobladas bonito no y estás en ese
día en en cree estado está la corretiza
y te juro que quieres quieres quieres
sacarle las canas cuando ves que tu hijo
sigue pegado al xbox o jugando formato o
en minecraft no lo dije ya por 15 aves
vete y arréglate porque ya va a llegar
la gente
te juro que te quedas con los dientes en
la esquina no entonces este bueno ya por
ciento dijo la verdad es lo que hace
súbete te entiendes y tú sigues en todos
los detalles y empieza a llegar la gente
bueno entonces empieza a llegar
de esos esos primos que ni te sabes los
nombres pero queda con decir primordial
libras que no que por cierto es algo que
me encanta meter hoy aquí si sus primos
ya ya te abrazan no dices walter qué
fácil me la ponen este entonces pues
bueno pues ya estás en eso ya está ya
todo mundo se empieza a contar llegan
los abuelos todo mundo felices y te juro
que te quieres quedar sin uno de tus
hijos cuando tu angelito ya por fin baja
de su cuarto en su mejor atuendo no lo
quieres degollar no hay bicis que esto
no que es esto para mí que te digo
cuando tienen a un mejor estilo no
diciendo buena gana
si este no salió de mí o cuando tu
princesita se dice que se dice oye qué
bien se ve este este pues sí sí eso es
eso es algo que pasa pero pero pero no
nos hagamos tontos o sea ahorita lo
vemos claro desde el punto de vista de
unos centímetros más de altura pero la
realidad que todos fuimos iguales todos
somos exactamente iguales yo me acuerdo
un día una en un fatídico día desde que
mi padre organizó tenía una cuestión de
una escena muy importante en su casa y
tuvo la mala fortuna de aplicar el
término es que va a ser un evento
imperial no es que va a ser
suena importantísimos y me dijo cuida o
sea le pones atención y esto tiene que
salir súper bien y lo que tú quieras
imperial imperial mar barcón pues para
mí ahora nada más difícil dije perfecto
estoy a texto en el lugar ideal por qué
por qué punto y aparte de que se lo que
se refiere pues yo puedo rápidamente
aplicar mi mejor sentido imperial al
asunto y presentarme en el atuendo
perfecto para lo que
no les quiero decir cuantas descuentos
nalgadas metieron por esa brillante
ocurrencia no pero este pero bueno es
parte de pero la realidad es que hacemos
estas cosas no por otra cosa sino por el
hecho de que admiramos estas
personalidades de que vemos estos
personajes vemos estas figuras e
inmediatamente nos sentimos conectados
no decimos oye pues es que estoy puesto
quiero ser yo mano esto está esto está
padrísimo esto esto es tienen tantos
atributos quizás como ni cómo ni cómo no
sentirme atraído hacia ellos no entonces
que nuevamente viene de un buen lugar
generalmente viene de la naturaleza
humana de la inspiración
pero los años pasan digamos que dejamos
estas estas estas cuestiones tan
infantiles y seguimos creciendo pero no
dejamos de seguir creciendo como buenos
seres humanos entonces nos seguimos
inspirando al pasar de los años dicen
sabes que si de verdad no me voy a poner
mi casco de darth vader no pero pero les
confieso que los niveles de violencia
que se alcanzaron en nuestro lecho
familiar fueron fueron intensos cuando
mi siguiente fuente de inspiración
resultó hacer algo como esto
ok debo de reconocer que obviamente
había había cierta disonancia de estilos
y de gustos y de iu de fuentes de
inspiración
pero pero no lo podía evitar para mi
estas figuras estos personajes porque
los adornos son personajes
pues representaban tanto representa
tanto la conexión con lo que yo
consideraba válido o valioso
representativo y demás pues no podía
evitar no podía evitar les seguir los
pasos no entonces de alguna forma es
parte de irte poniendo en esas digamos
muletas que eventualmente incorporan tu
libertad o tu individualidad y
autonomista ya no las necesito y las
botas y dices bueno ya ya puedo ser yo
mismo ya ya ya logré logré pasar por los
por los tropiezos de la adolescencia y
habilitando el tablero en adulto no y ya
cuando te vuelves un adulto pues ya dice
sea es que es que éste ya estoy yo caray
lo logras que no se fijan como el
proceso de inspiración eventualmente te
llega a aprobar tantos sabores de helado
que eventualmente dice observar el mío
el mío el mío es ese la vainilla no hizo
la verdad es que salud por eso
caballeros y damas la verdad es que
salud por eso por qué porque no es fácil
es un es un trayecto que la verdad
llegamos aquí por por una combinación de
suerte nalgadas y
e inspiración entonces salud por eso
salud por eso como diría calibrar con un
cosmopolita en la mano la verdad o un
poquito más cercano a mi corazón bueno
ni que les digo en este una pasión como
el buen don driver que garay es y como
no es totalmente este entonces es bueno
no les puede negar que tanto el cosmo
como el loud fashion fueron fueron cosas
que a lo mejor nos hubiera dado tanta
importancia hasta que no vi estos estos
estos personajes disfrutarlos tanto no
entonces pues vaya definitivamente no
puedo negar que siguen siendo
referencial para un adulto como tal no y
bueno si ya nos vamos ya muchísimo más
adelante o lo ponemos más en términos un
poquito más amplios más allá de las
preferencias etílicas está pues alguien
como john snow no sea ni que le decimos
este son sólo está padrísima está está
padrísimo o sea puede con todos va
contra todas las circunstancias más más
difíciles la libra o sea es que contra
todo lo que el todo todo lo que el
destino la 'roja'
no sale triunfador no a veces es un
personaje muy muy padre entonces no es
no es malo no es no es ilógico es que
nos inspiré muchísimo no y que la verdad
si yo también si me quiero poner una
capa otra vez de vez en cuando no esté
sale la imagen de mi madre y mi
habitación dentro de ti no no
pero lo que quiero decirles con esto es
de que definitivamente el componente
heroico vuelve a surgir una y una y otra
vez en diferentes formas en diferentes
iteraciones y vuelve a cobrar la fuerza
que siempre ha tenido
pero lo que quiero proponerles aquí yo
lo que les quiero platicar con esto es
primero que nada una confesión
en hollywood vamos a pasar
horas días semanas meses de largas y
largas sesiones diseñando escribiendo
pensando imaginando cómo va a ser el
personaje que va a ser la que vaya la
culminación de todos los dotes humanos
para poder para que sea una figura que
inspira es decir es un es un proceso de
muchísimo tiempo donde lo que se está
donde el único objetivo es generar un
personaje que inspira a los demás
entonces no podemos ninguno de nosotros
sentirnos culpables del hecho a la hora
que sale pues nos inspiramos pero es un
proceso chicos es una es un laboratorio
donde estamos probando diferentes
combinaciones para saber cuál es la cuál
es el modelo absoluto que va a funcionar
para el prototipo del héroe total y este
y por lo mismo pues pues es un proceso
sintético de alguna forma esto no es yo
no nunca nunca nunca estuve en mi
escuela al menos que yo recuerden
entonces la verdad es que este proceso
sintético pues nos lo tenemos que
entender como tal entonces mi propuesta
mi propuesta esta noche es decir no a
johnson
como lo dibujamos en tres en tres horas
jones nou no es tan emocionante tan
divertido tan increíblemente audaz tan
tan tan capaz de tener las aventuras más
emocionantes inconcebibles como un
personaje que les voy a presentar esta
noche ese personaje es ustedes
cada uno de ustedes tiene la capacidad
de ser un personaje infinitamente más
elaborado más emocionante más divertido
más trágico más heroico que cualquier
grande que jamás podemos describir la
primera razón de eso es porque ustedes
están vivos
entonces el hecho de que ustedes sean
seres humanos vivos coleando y
decidiendo cada segundo cada cada
instante de sus vidas lo que quieren
hacer de ellas les permite les tienen
ahora sí que la libertad absoluta de
hacer de ellas algo maravilloso sin
tenerse que pelear con otros diez
creativos que juran y perjuran que jones
no debería usar una capa blanca en vez
de una negra no si me explico no hay
debate no hay no hay no hay una no hay
esa mesa redonda de personas pero eso no
es que debiera hacer esto no no no no
aquí sólo hay una persona que toma esa
decisión y esa persona es ustedes cada
uno de ustedes entonces yo quiero yo
quiero proponerles que en vez de tener
que estar
digamos a inspirados de estar nos siguen
siendo inspirados por la vida de estos
de estas figuras o por la vida de una
hora a la semana que vemos de estas
figuras nos inspiramos con nosotros
mismos nos inspiramos con nosotros
mismos y empezamos a vivir una aventura
de nuestras vidas que es mucho mucho más
satisfactoria que va se va a volver se
los garantizo que se hablar mucho más
satisfactoria que cualquiera de las de
las ficciones que vemos en cine
televisión y demás medios y para lograr
esto sólo se trata de una cosa de tener
cierto nivel de prudente audacia quizás
para un lado más que para el otro ya
cada quien decidirá pero definitivamente
es cuestión de audacia es cuestión de
bueno no vamos a subirnos a un dragón en
cada mañana evidentemente pero sí vamos
a poder decir sabes que ese momento
donde dónde estás en el bar y está la
chava que te supero vuelve loco me estás
haciendo te tarugo porque sabes que te
gustaría llegarle se sabe es que al
[ __ ] mano escribe la nota en la
servilleta y se la pasas mano y te va a
voltear a ver con una cara de perón y en
tus sueños
no no lo han intentado y todo te vas a
sentir la chinche más más más plana de
la galaxia pero sabes que eso fue una
pequeña aventura eso fue una aventura
que tú viviste ese día y que se te va a
quedar de por vida
pero pero eso es parte de precisamente
el episodio de ese día si me explico ese
fue parte eso es parte de lo que ahora
dices
el día de ayer estuvo estuvo padrísimo
si me batearon como las grandes ligas no
no importa eso eso fue ese episodio y a
lo mejor ese es el nuevo día que empieza
te vas te vas a ponerte en la posición
de hacer un nuevo episodio de ti mismo
donde ahora sabes que te vas a aventar a
pedir ese aumento y que crees en una de
esas y le pegas
y te tienes que sentir donde me dieron
la oficina de al lado no ya salí del
cubículo no está padre o sea pero lo
tienes que empezar a decidir
al terminar de una forma en la que de
verdad se constituye una una vida
emocionante si es posible siempre y
cuando lo hagamos o sea no es no estamos
no estamos en una condición en la cual
estamos limitados para hacerlo y hay de
todo tipo de sabores y líder ante cada
uno de nosotros sabe exactamente cuáles
son esos sabores o cuáles son esas
oportunidades pero hay que tomarlas hay
que tomarlas y sobre todo algo bien
importante si yo puedo eso en raid rama
y qué quiere decir con el raid rama no
pasa nada no pasa nada yo siempre digo
lo mejor de romperse todos los huesos es
que sabes cuál es el más bueno de todos
los que tienen
en verdad tropieza te equivocas te
frustra te todo esto todo esto y al
final de cuentas no pasa nada y ya va a
haber drama y va a haber va a haber
tragedia y por qué es tan importante en
racing drama porque el drama es un
componente indispensable para hacer una
historia entretenida para hacer una
historia emocionante si no hay trama
pues no hay no hay emociones y por eso
no nos aburrimos cuando un superman
porque no le pasa nada
y eventualmente la exquisita de la
kriptonita ya llega a ser hasta media
ocurrirá no entonces si algo no le pasa
a nadie es invulnerable todo sale
perfecto todo está bien nunca sabe a
nada no sabe a nada es insípido
necesitamos el saber el cómo sabe el
café negro para que a la hora que cuando
le pones leche digas ag pues no está tan
mal sé qué rico está esto y encuentras
dónde está ese balance dónde acabas con
tu café turbio no como yo le digo este
pero es indispensable el gris es un
color maravilloso pero sólo lo podemos
conocer cuando conocimos el blanco y el
negro entonces todas estas pruebas y
errores te permiten encontrar el drama
dentro de la vida qué es lo que lo hace
emocionante
y no estoy queriendo decir con esto que
apoyo nuestro apoyo a una moción de ahí
vamos a ser dramáticos no no no no no
estoy diciendo que generemos drama sino
que más bien no nos importe si existe si
sucede en nuestras vidas si cualquier
evento por más triste que sea le podemos
dar la vuelta de una forma tan tan tan
padre utiliza la fuerza de tu oponente
como dicen en aikido este para volver
algo muy padre para genera algo muy
padre para disfrutar el hecho de que
saben que me quedé solo saben que osea
estoy estoy recorriendo las calles
lluviosas y entonces empieza a generar
este soundtrack en la cabeza
lalalala y es padrísimo humano está
increíble o sea la hora que voltea es de
un mes después vemos tal solicitud
ay qué padres tuvo ese momento que padre
este yo no les puedo decir honestamente
qué cantidad de veces los mejores de los
mejores han hecho desde mi vida está
cuando se me ha ido un avión es
buenísimo la cantidad de drama que pasó
por cinco minutos sale no no no es así
es indiscutible es sexy genial me
encantan entonces que pasen las
tragedias no nadie se va a morir no pasa
nada y por último esto nos va a llevar a
que con todas estas secciones con todas
estas estas vivencias que vamos estos
estos digamos obstáculos que vamos
librando y que vamos brincando el que a
veces estábamos volando nos vamos
convirtiendo en nuestro propio héroe nos
vamos convirtiendo en ese héroe que
decimos a es que qué padre está lo que
estás viviendo que padre es verte no sé
qué padre es ver tu serie que padres
cada episodio que tengo el show de mahou
de cada mañana o el show de cada uno de
ustedes cada mañana es el show que más
quiero ver
las tapas haremos menos tiempo viendo
viendo la pantalla de la televisión y
más viendo lo que está enfrente de
nosotros que somos el protagonista
absoluto y que somos aquel aquel héroe
que va a poder va a poder emocionarnos
más que cualquier otro
gracias por serlo gracias por serlo
gracias por en este momento escucharlo y
estoy seguro que todos y cada uno de
ustedes en su en su justa perspectiva ya
lo es entonces aumenten su rating vean
se más a sí mismos y disfrútenlo porque
es un genial programa muchas gracias
[Aplausos]